Bell in the city he knows the capital of
Germany and it used to be communist well
that wasn't built by Donald Trump
my name is Emma laser let's get to it
the origin of the name Berlin according
to most German sources is derived from
the word dart meaning bear which would
explain the barreling coat of arms
having a bear on it
however this origin is unlikely as
barren ancient Germanic is Bern and yes
this is why the Swiss capital is called
birth and the bearing coat of arms even
though dating to the 13th century didn't
become relevant until the 18th century
more likely origin of the name Berlin
comes from the plebeian vestian Slavs
who inhabited this marshy and swampy
land and named it Barrow orbital meaning
swamp even though the settlement in the
Berlin area can be traced all the way to
the 4th century BCE it wasn't much of a
major establishment created back then
even the Slavic tribes who settled the
area didn't create a major settlement
before their arrival the dramatic traps
in the 11th century the original Slavic
town of Berlin was on the eastern bank
of the Spree River as the Germanic traps
arrived to the area and they settled the
opposite side of the river and found in
a new city cone on an island of the
Spree River now called museum Island so
as from 12th century onward Bella needs
to be known as Valentin Kohl majesty
Island also in the 12th century barely
Lincoln came under German rule as part
of the at the time major principality of
Margraviate brandenburg then in 13th
century barely Lincoln were given their
first town charters and the year of 1237
is taken as the official founding year
of their life in consecutive years
barrelling comb grew in population lost
the germanic as they profited from the
lucrative trade between the Hanseatic
League this trade wasn't solely
conducted through the Spree River as
there was also an intricate web of land
trade routes in which Maryland played a
vital role in the 14th century as the
city grew in population I was hit by the
devastating Black Death and also several
of highly destructive fires nevertheless
at the end of the 14th century there
were around 8,000 people living in
Berlin and calm however this wasn't much
compared to other German cities at the
time for example Cologne which had 5
times the population during the 15 and
17th century there was a large expansion
in Berlin comb in 1432 the two cities
merged in foreign Berlin and in 1451 and
became the Royal resident of the
Brandenburg Anna lectures because of
this Berlin had to renounce its free
city status of the Hanseatic League
main income shifted from trading to
producing goods and services to the
rising noble class in the city meanwhile
during this time due to fires plagues
migration assimilation and
discrimination the Slavic population of
Berlin became almost non-existent
nevertheless swelling during power in
population during his 15 - 17th century
at the start of the 17th century Berlin
was hit hard by the aftermath of the 30
Years War where 1/3 of the houses were
damaged or destroyed and the city lost
half of its population during the 18th
and 19th century barreling through
strunk mostly the military base for the
powerful and aggressive Prussia and
later on the German Empire during this
time Berlin was home to large barracks
and also multiple military factories
manufacturing weapons it also had a
fast-growing science and engineering
sector which was mostly focused on
military technology during the 19th and
very early 20th century Berlin had a
poor sanitary condition and a high need
of infrastructure improvement this
improvement came after 1870 when
scientists and engineers were brought in
to not only solve Berlin problems but
also improved Berlin as a whole Berlin
underwent a large rebuilding an
immersive the world model city complete
with everything from parks to sewers to
even a subway then in 1914 World War one
started during the World War 1 Berlin
remained strong as bureaucratic German
rationing was effective enough to keep
the city going after World War 1 Berlin
became the capital of the vamo Republic
during which as the rest of Germany it
struggled at the start and then
completely fell into disrepair with high
unemployment from this depression the
Nazi Party came to power promising to
rebuild Germany back to its glory during
the Third Reich Hitler had large plans
to rebuild Berlin and his image however
these weren't executed due to lack of
resources during World War 2 after World
War 2 Berlin was in ruins as massive
Allied air strikes were conducted on the
city during the war as the city was
rebuilt it was split into two parts the
American and the USSR well at least
that's what the Americans like to think
actually the Western Berlin was divided
into British French and American areas
of influence respectively this was also
the time in 1948 when massive air lists
have been dropping food to West Berlin
as the Soviets blockaded the city due to
various political reasons
during this time then famous Berlin Wall
was constructed around West Berlin and
ironically was called the anti-fascist
protection wall by the USSR nevertheless
thousands of people tried to escape into
West Berlin some succeeded and some
sadly didn't thankfully in the November
of 1989 on no official direct order
border guards allowed crowds of people
to cross to West Berlin from east and
mortar was opened ever since
3rd of October 1990 was when Berlin was
reunited along with the rest of Germany
for good and after decades of violence
and Germans turbulence 20th century it
was reunited at the end
thank you for watching in five minutes
or less a series where I pick a city and
explain its history in five minutes or
less please leave suggestions for the
next city down below in the comments
thank you